The Cancer Genome Atlas (TCGA) is a landmark
cancer genomics program to molecularly characterized
over 11,000 primary cancer and matched normal
samples spanning 33 cancer types.
The joint effort between NCI and the National
Human Genome Research Institute began in 2006,
bringing together researchers from diverse
disciplines and multiple institutions.
Over the past 15 years, TCGA has generated
over 2.5 petabytes of genomic, epigenomic,
transcriptomic, and proteomic data.
The data, which has already led to improvements
in our ability to diagnose, treat, and prevent
cancer, will remain publicly available for
anyone in the research community to use.
All data collected and processed by the program
is currently available at the NCI Cancer Research
Data Commons (CRDC).
The NCI Cancer Research Data Commons (CRDC)
is a cloud-based data science infrastructure
that connects data sets with analytics tools
to allow users to share, integrate, analyze,
and visualize cancer research data to drive
scientific discovery.
In addition to the TCGA data, CRDC also provides
access to data from other NCI programs such
as the Therapeutically Applicable Research
to Generate Effective Treatments (TARGET),
and The Clinical Proteomics Tumor Analysis
Consortium (CPTAC), through various platforms:
• Genomic Data Commons (GDC)
• Proteomic Data Commons (PDC)
• Imaging Data Commons (IDC)
• Cancer Data Service (CDS)
• Integrated Canine Data Commons (ICDC)
• Clinical Trial Data Commons (CTDC)
The Genomic Data Commons (GDC) Data Portal
provides users with web-based access to data
from cancer genomics studies.
The front page displays a summary of all available
datasets.
The GDC Data Portal provides five navigation
options for browsing available harmonized
datasets.
These include the navigations based on project,
exploration, analysis, repository or human
anatomical sites.
Each view provides a distinct representation
of the same underlying set of GDC data and
metadata.
The toolbar available at the top of all pages
in the GDC Data Portal also provides convenient
navigation links and access to authentication
and quick search.
The left portion of this toolbar provides
access to the Home Page, Projects Page, Exploration
Page, Analysis Page, and a link to Repository
Page.
The right portion of this toolbar provides
access to quick search, manage sets, authentication
functions, the cart, and the GDC Apps menu.
The Projects link directs users to the Projects
Page, which gives an overall summary of project-level
information, including the available data
for each project.
It also provides filtering, navigation, and
advanced visualization features that allow
users to identify and browse projects of interest.
On the left, a panel of facets allow users
to apply filters to find projects of interest.
When facet filters are applied, the table
and visualizations on the right are updated
to display only the matching projects.
When no filters are applied, all projects
are displayed.
The top right side of the Projects Page displays
a few visualizations of the data such as the
Top Mutated Genes in Selected Projects and
Case Distribution per Project.
Hovering the cursor over each bar will display
information about the number of cases affected
by the disease type and clicking on each bar
will launch the Gene Summary Page for the
gene associated with the mutation.
Users can toggle the Y-Axis of this bar graph
between a percentage or raw number of cases
affected.
Below these graphs is a table that contains
a list of projects and details about each
project, such as the number of cases and data
files.
The table provides links to Project Summary
Pages in the Project ID column.
Columns with file and case counts include
links to open the corresponding files or cases
in Repository Page.
The Graph tab contains an interactive view
of information in the Table tab.
The numerical values in Case Count, File Count,
and File Size columns are represented by bars
of varying length according to size.
These columns are sorted independently in
descending order.
Mousing over an element of the graph connects
it to associated elements in other columns,
including Project ID and major Primary Sites.
Most elements in the graph are clickable,
allowing the user to open the associated cases
or files in Repository Page.
Like the projects table, the graph will reflect
any applied facet filters.
The Exploration Page allows users to explore
data in the GDC using advanced filters, which
includes those on a gene and mutation level.
Users choose filters on specific Cases, Genes
or Mutations on the left of this page and
then can visualize these results on the right.
There is also a Clinical tab with filters
that apply specifically to clinical data.
As users add filters to the data on the Exploration
Page, the Results section will automatically
be updated.
Results are divided into different tabs: Cases,
Genes, Mutations, and OncoGrid.
The Cases tab gives an overview of all the
cases who correspond to the filters chosen.
The top of this section contains a few pie
graphs with categorical information regarding
the Primary Site, Project, Disease Type, Gender,
and Vital Status.
Below these pie charts is a tabular view of
cases, which can be exported, sorted and saved
using the buttons on the right.
The Case Summary Page displays case details
including the project and disease information,
data files that are available for that case,
and the experimental strategies employed.
The Genes tab will give an overview of all
the genes that match the criteria of the filters.
The top of this tab contains a bar graph of
the most frequently mutated genes.
Hovering over each bar in the plot will display
information about the percentage of cases
affected.
In addition, this section contains a survival
curve.
The survival curve is calculated using the
Kaplan-Meier estimator based on all cases
with survival data within the specified Exploration
Page search.
Users may choose to download the underlying
data in JSON or TSV format or an image of
the graph in SVG or PNG format by clicking
the download icon at the top of each graph.
Gene Summary Pages describe each gene with
mutation data and provides results related
to the analyses that are performed on these
genes.
A table shows how many cases are affected
by mutations and copy number variation within
the gene as a ratio and percentage.
Under the protein view, mutations and their
frequency across cases are mapped to a graphical
visualization of protein-coding regions with
a lollipop plot.
Pfam domains are highlighted along the x-axis
to assign functionality to specific protein-coding
regions.
The bottom track represents a view of the
full gene length.
Different transcripts can be selected by using
the drop-down menu above the plot.
The panel to the right of the plot allows
the plot to be filtered by mutation consequences
or impact.
The plot will dynamically change as filters
are applied.
Mutation consequence and impact is denoted
in the plot by color.
The Mutations tab contains information about
one somatic mutation and how it affects the
associated gene.
Each mutation is identified by its chromosomal
position and nucleotide-level change.
A table shows how many cases are affected
by the particular mutation.
You can compare the effects of different mutations
on the survival curve.
The Exploration Page also includes an OncoGrid
plot of the cases with the most mutations,
for the top 50 mutated genes affected by high
impact mutations.
Genes displayed on the left of the y-axis
correspond to individual cases on the X-axis.
Additionally, the plot also indicates in each
cell any CNV events detected for these top
mutated cases and genes.
The grid is color-coded with a legend at the
top which describes what type of mutation
consequence and CNV event is observed for
each gene and case combination.
Clinical information and the available data
for each case are available at the bottom
of the grid.
In addition to the Exploration Page, the GDC
Data Portal also has features used to save
and compare sets of cases, genes, and mutations.
These sets can either be generated with existing
filters or through custom selection.
There are three tabs on this page.
The users can select either to do Set Operations,
Cohort Comparison or Clinical Data Analysis.
The Results tab is where users can view the
results of current or previous set analyses.
Finally, the Repository Page is the primary
method of accessing data in the GDC Data Portal.
The individual file can either be downloaded
individually from File Summary Pages or collected
in the file cart to be downloaded as a bundle.
Clicking on the shopping cart icon that is
next to any item in the GDC will add the item
to your cart.